[Music]
on this tuesday night canada moves
closer to tighter travel restrictions
concern about contagious new variants
prompts new plans
nothing is off the table and manitoba
puts in tough new quarantine rules
as suspected cases of the covid19
variant surge in ontario
it seems likely that the measures we
have in place right now won't be enough
plus a potential new threat to canada's
vaccine supply
and sticking to their bubbles
a new weird way to stage a rock concert
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a staggering new milestone
in the pandemic the world has now
surpassed 100 million
known cases of the coronavirus and more
than 2.1 million people
are known to have died from it now the
rise of new more contagious variants
poses a new threat and is prompting
tighter travel restrictions
germany is considering a ban on almost
all international air travel
israel has already done that the us is
banning most visitors from countries
where new variants have been detected
including south africa brazil the uk and
dozens of european countries
and new zealand is warning its borders
will likely stay closed to visitors
for the rest of this year today prime
minister justin trudeau said a number of
new measures are being considered
here when it comes to protecting you
and your family nothing is off the table
we will not hesitate to take even
tougher measures if
and when they're needed
exactly what measures and when they'll
be announced is not clear
manitoba's premier is not prepared to
wait and today he announced tough new
rules for anyone entering that province
michael couture has our top story
tonight
to ensure that anyone returning to
manitoba
including western canada must
self-isolate for a period of 14 days
the order applies to all non-essential
travel
premier brian pallister believes this is
the only way to protect his province
against variants of covet 19 which
haven't been detected in manitoba
yet restrictions also have to be brought
into place and made real by the federal
government
and enforcement has to follow and the
pleas aren't just
political dozens of physicians and
researchers are calling on the federal
government
to tighten up the border now when we're
looking at how quickly these variants
are transmitting
doing full restrictions for
non-essential travel i think is
certainly within our playbook we are
looking at
even further restrictions on travel
while hinting something
more is coming prime minister justin
trudeau points out travel restrictions
imposed
since the start of the pandemic have
helped
according to canada border services
agency between last march and january of
this year
more than 30 thousand foreign nationals
were denied entry into canada from the
u.s
because it was deemed non-essential in
addition to that
756 people arriving by air from foreign
countries
were sent back but stopping all
commercial flights into the country
could have consequences we know that
many commercial flights transporting
passengers
also carry goods in the belly of those
planes we need to make sure that we are
not interrupting our supply line
as we strengthen those measures those
supply lines include the u.s and mexico
a u.s state department spokesperson
tells global news the three countries
are discussing
the implementation of science-based
protocols
along the shared borders donna
okay mike lucature in ottawa thanks more
cases of the new variants are being
reported every day in canada including
today
dozens of suspected cases in a care home
in ontario
a growing number of cases have no known
link to someone who recently traveled
from another country
that's an indication of community spread
eric sorenson explains what we know and
don't know
about the rise of these new variants the
news could hardly be worse for the
roberta place
long-term care home more than 200
residents and staff were diagnosed in a
rapid outbreak of covet 19
more than 40 have died the public health
unit at first identified the uk variant
in seven cases
but across the region it now reports an
additional 99
positives for the uk variant the
majority from
roberta place the medical officer of
health says these preliminary results
suggest two cases have no known link to
the recent outbreak
roberto place had something
extraordinarily difficult to deal with
with
just how rapid rapidly this spread
through the facilities it moved very
fast i think
that speaks to the nature of this uk
variant that it can do that
across the country covet variant cases
are climbing british columbia has
detected both uk and south african
variants
modeling by simon fraser university
researchers shows
similar projections for the provinces
with the most cases
the new variant in red may come later in
alberta a little sooner and more
aggressively in ontario
but the national picture is this the
covet 19 virus may be peaking in january
and fall off
in february but the new variant if it
becomes established with a
40 percent higher transmission rate will
start building in february
and could take off in march hitting
numbers of cases far beyond anything
we've seen to date
if you drop something with a high
transmission rate into the system what's
it going to do it's going to grow
exponentially so the thing is a higher
transmission rate
means that it seems likely that the
measures we have in place right now
won't be enough
one expert says canadians will have to
buckle down that deterring further
travel is one measure
but we must continue social distancing
what's the most important for the
variance is making sure we don't forget
about our tried and true principles of
infection prevention and control
because these are the things that we
know are going to be able to
decrease the amount of covet in the
community variant or not
there is increasing urgency to get
vaccines distributed
especially for long-term care residents
but the persistence of covet 19 and the
rapid growth of the covet variants
will have to be dealt with before
large-scale vaccinations can take place
eric sorensen global news toronto
with vaccines the big focus right now
there's been less talk of rapid testing
but experts say the devices are key
in the fight to containing outbreaks the
federal government says it has procured
tens of millions of rapid tests but
only a small portion of them are in use
and as abigail beeman reports
access depends on where you live we've
got your health card
pop-up sites in nova scotia i thought i
would come in
and make sure i'm still good two high
schools in montreal
vancouver's downtown east side and
long-term care homes in places across
the country
they all have rapid test pilot programs
but only pilots months after the first
tests were approved
the national testing and screening
advisory panel calls antigen test
deployment
a priority in a new report we need the
federal government to
procure more of them we need the federal
government to approve
more of them and then we need the
provincial governments to
support the more rapid use and wide
scale use of them
let me just say that we have procured
over 40.5 million rapid tests
but only 15.4 million have actually
arrived the rest to get here by the end
of march
i don't know where this has gone but
rapid testing to me would be an absolute
game changer
as managers and administrators turn
their attention to the vaccine rollout
what we've seen in a number of provinces
is that testing volumes are going down
dr irfan dala says no one knows for sure
why
rapid testing hasn't been happening more
rapidly but he points to an
overstretched health care system with
attention on the vaccine
and a tendency to prefer a higher
quality test
the gold standard pcr lab test the
antigen test for all the benefits that
it can be quicker and easier and cheaper
the downside is is that you do get more
false negatives and some of the rapid
antigen tests do have up to a 30 percent
a false
negative because of that antigen tests
are recommended for screening purposes
in targeted populations
and many provinces require any positive
results to be confirmed by a lab
everybody wants more
and we are just trying to keep up with
demand
the other type of rapid test uses
nucleic acid closer to pcr in terms of
results but more expensive and
complicated than antigen tests
cepheid's fluvid test is one of the
latest nucleic acid rapid tests approved
by health canada it tests for flu as
well as covid
we're really focusing on sick patients
coming into the hospital where it really
matters to have
a very sensitive and specific
technologies dr dave persing doesn't
think canada is behind in terms of
procurement
but he won't give specifics so where's
canada on that list in terms of
how much we've purchased from you
compared to other places
i don't want to get into that because
it'll be a little controversial
canada's top doctor says she is hearing
about more jurisdictions implementing
rapid testing teresa tam says as case
numbers fall
it's important rapid testing capacity is
in place before restrictions
ease abigail beeman global news ottawa
there's a potential new hurdle for
canada's vaccine supply the european
union is threatening to limit
exports of covid19 doses canada's supply
of pfizer biotech vaccines are
manufactured in europe
today the prime minister said he is
working to ensure shipments
aren't disrupted we will of course
continue to work closely with
our european allies and counterparts to
ensure that there are
not any disruptions to the canadian
supply chain
a little later we'll explain why the eu
is threatening to limit
vaccine exports some help manufacturing
vaccines is on the way thanks to a
french pharmaceutical giant sanofi says
it will produce
more than 100 million doses of the
pfizer biotech covid19 vaccine by the
end of the year
the company and its british partner
glaxosmithkline have delayed the launch
of their own vaccine
to late 2021. one big disadvantage
canada has in the vaccine rollout is a
lack of manufacturing in this country
a canadian pharmaceutical company is
hoping to change that
providence therapeutics has begun phase
one of human trials of its vaccine
candidate
if it passes all the necessary clinical
trials and gets approved for use
the company hopes to produce it in
calgary heather urix west reports on the
canadian made
vaccine candidate two canadian companies
are hoping this twenty thousand square
foot facility in calgary
will be manufacturing covet 19 vaccine
by early next year
having that capacity in canada is is
truly important and for national
security and for economic well-being the
mrna vaccine developed by providence
therapeutics
has just started phase one human trials
the company's ceo brad sorensen
hopes to begin phase two by may we've
got a lot of planning and collaboration
that we have to do with health canada
for our phase two and phase three
and we also expect that there'll be an
international component to that phase
three trial
right now canada simply does not have
capacity to produce the millions of
doses
needed to protect canadians from the new
coronavirus the pfizer biantec and
moderna vaccines are all produced in
other countries
it's why providence decided to partner
with calgary-based northern rna
to build manufacturing infrastructure
too
our phase one is we're actually going to
be manufacturing some of the components
of the vaccine phase two when we do an
expansion of our facility or actually a
restructuring of our facility which is
now going to be much faster than we had
previously thought
that's when we're actually going to be
manufacturing the vaccines still
even if clinical trials go well the
earliest the providence vaccine could be
ready for final health canada approval
is next year here's the fundamental
problem get approval for a vaccine
you have to go through phase three
trials and those trials typically enroll
some thirty thousand forty thousand
fifty thousand patients
are you going to find volunteers in
those numbers
who are willing to try an untested
unproven
unknown vaccine if it means that they
must sacrifice getting pfizers or
modernis or somebody else's
but as new variants of the virus emerge
sorensen believes the demand for new
versions of the covid19 vaccine will
continue for years to come
and a domestic manufacturing source
could ensure canada always has access to
supply
heather eric's west global news calgary
some disturbing news from newfoundland
and labrador police have arrested a man
who had a large number of knives in his
truck
outside a political candidate's office
liberal leader and incumbent premier
andrew fury was likely the intended
target according to his spokesperson
police arrested the man after a
high-speed chase that began with a
suspect saying he was going to the town
of deer lake
where fury is running to stop the
election
an ambitious goal for america coming up
how u.s president joe biden hopes to end
racial injustice
i ran for president because i believe
we're in a battle for the soul of this
nation
and the simple truth is our soul will be
troubled as long as systemic racism is
allowed to persist
we can't eliminate it's not gonna be
overnight we can't eliminate everything
but it's corrosive it's destructive and
it's costly
it cost every american
president joe biden setting a new tone
for america he signed four executive
orders today he says will advance racial
equity in america
they target discriminatory housing
policies voting rights
health care and criminal justice biden
says it is
a step towards healing racial tensions
across the country
and is the right thing to do he says
right now because all americans will be
better off for it
this afternoon president biden made his
first phone call to russian president
vladimir putin
the white house says biden raised a
number of issues including concern about
the arrest of opposition leader alexei
navalny
reports russia had placed bounties on
u.s soldiers in afghanistan
and russian interference in the 2020
election
former u.s president donald trump was
accused by critics of not being forceful
enough with putin
a russian statement says putin today
congratulated biden on winning the
election
and the two agreed to maintain
consistent communication
and janet yellen was sworn in today as
the first woman to lead the u.s
treasury in the institution's 232-year
history
congratulations madam secretary
congratulations
yellen is expected to play a pivotal
role in gaining congressional approval
of president joe biden's 1.9
trillion dollar covid19 relief package
a huge cleanup is underway in central
alabama after a tornado ripped through
late last night with little notice it
carved a path of destruction 16
kilometers long
a teenage boy was killed and members of
his family injured
as they huddled in the basement of their
home dozens of other people were injured
too and a search is underway
to find the missing ahead europe
threatens
to tighten its grip on vaccines what it
may mean for canada
there is another potential vaccine
hurdle on the horizon for canada
the european union is threatening to
block exports of vaccines to countries
outside europe
and it's accused astrazeneca of failing
to guarantee the delivery of its vaccine
without a valid
explanation all of it a sign the
distribution of vaccines is becoming
more protectionist and
political redmond shannon looks at what
it could mean
for canada the oxford university
astrazeneca covid19 vaccine has been
called
a game changer because it's easy to
store and it's cheap
it became even more important after
pfizer announced rollout delays with its
vaccine
but now astrazeneca also says it can't
meet early delivery commitments to the
european union
we should remember that what we're
trying to do collectively here
has never been done in the history of
the world that developed a vaccine of
several vaccines in that instance in a
year
and then scale up to billions of doses
astrazeneca says it's a manufacturing
issue
the eu is skeptical the answers of the
company
have not been satisfactory so far
the vaccine was rolled out in the uk
just days after brexit was completed
the european union wants to know exactly
which doses have been produced where by
astrazeneca
so far and if or to whom
they have been delivered the eu is
threatening to force vaccine companies
to reveal where their exports are going
it is critical to not be dependent on
imports so that astrazeneca vaccine
should be approved
it should be manufactured in canada
tooling up can take time a vaccine
factory is currently under construction
at this national research council site
in montreal
we've got good facilities here in canada
but growing that
will be important i think it will secure
the supply for canadians
and protect against future viruses
health canada is waiting for the eu
to approve the astrazeneca vaccine
before it makes its approval decision
meanwhile two german news reports that
claim that the astrazeneca vaccine is
less than 10 percent effective for
seniors
have been dismissed as completely
incorrect by the drugs maker
the german government says the reports
are both confused
and mixed up donna
redmond shannon in london thanks well if
you've got dinosaur fans in your house
here's a story for you researchers have
discovered a tyrannosaur hatchling a
cousin
of the fierce tyrannosaurus rex and they
think they know what it looked like and
how big it was
the team discovered a jawbone and a claw
in alberta and montana the first known
fossils of
tyrannosaur embryos they're more than 70
million years old and reveal the
hatchling would have been about
90 centimeters long about the size of a
border coley
researchers say they would have been the
largest hatchlings to ever emerge from
eggs
and would have looked remarkably like
their parents
next a bc couple's scheme to jump the
queue and get vaccinated
there is staying in your bubble and then
there's this the flaming lips put their
fans and themselves in plastic bubbles
for a concert
the band claims it's safer than going to
the supermarket but medical
professionals
aren't so sure everyone is trying to
find a way to manage all the
restrictions these days so
the sneaky thing a bc couple did to jump
the queue and get vaccinated is getting
all kinds of attention
as robin gill reports what they
attempted involved a charter flight
a small town and lots of planning
rod baker comes from a wealthy family a
katarina baker
is an aspiring actress their story now
making headlines
around the world hitting especially hard
in the yukon times
from our perspective we were just
completely angry
frustrated with these folks
the couple's elaborate plot involved
flying from vancouver to whitehorse
checking into hotel for a couple of days
then chartering a private jet
to beaver creek beaver creek is a small
border town with
only about a hundred people the couple
apparently got into line for the vaccine
and pretended to be workers at a local
motel
no one in beaver creek suspected
anything until they asked for a ride
to the airport as the bakers were
boarding a flight
officers caught up with them and fined
them 2 300
for violating the 14-day quarantine they
should have taken
upon landing in yukon the vaccine was
intended for the white river first
nation living in this remote community
the closest hospital is five hours away
so indigenous leaders
are outraged my first thought was
privileged
they're being shamed good but that's not
enough
i see nothing less than a criminal
record for these people
and keep calm dr bonnie henry british
columbia's public health officer
wasn't so kind with her words they
should be ashamed of themselves
they put a community at risk for their
own benefit
and and that to me is appalling the
thing is the vaccine requires two doses
so a lot of effort went into getting the
first one
but what was the plan for the second
dose
guess we'll never know robin gill global
news vancouver
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's here
canada is the municipality of stuart
burn manitoba formed in 1902.
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
you